[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández hoy
los llevaremos a Colombia en el
departamento del chocó en el oeste del
país una decisión de la corte
constitucional permitió en el año 2016
que el río atrato se convirtiera en una
entidad sujeto de derecho una decisión
que sentó un precedente en el país
sudamericano esta resolución llegó a
raíz de denuncias pronunciadas por las
comunidades afros e indígenas debido a
la existencia de la explotación minera
por el uso de sustancias tóxicas que
representan un peligro contra la
supervivencia humana y que han dañado de
manera profunda del raudal seis años
después de que se firmara la sentencia
margotbazillón Lionel puzzerie de France
24 y María del diario francés Lemon
viajaron a quibdó para verificar la
situación actual del río atrato desde
que ocurrió la firma del fallo dos de
estas nos acompañan en el estudio
comienzo contigo Margot quería
preguntarte Margot el río atrato
se le ha podido respetar sus derechos
Como sujeto de derecho bueno como lo
vamos a ver en el reportaje ha sido muy
difícil hacer respetar esos derechos
entre los últimos años y quería agregar
algo que es que la principal dificultad
ha sido que al estado y las
instituciones en Colombia no están
preparadas para defender los derechos de
un río o de un ecosistema en su
complejidad también existen pruebas de
origen jurídico los derechos de la
naturaleza chocan con la inercia de las
leyes previas en Colombia los recursos
naturales como los ríos o de manera
general el agua o también los bosques se
pueden concesionar a privados porque en
la ley son vistos apenas como recursos
entonces hace falta crear contenidos
nuevos legalmente para que se pueda
aplicar Los guardianes del río que
trabajan en la i del fallo están
apoyados por la ong siembra que les
asesora en el proceso pero la ley tiene
que evolucionar para que haya de verdad
un cambio herminia Gracias marco ya
volvemos contigo María aquí la historia
[Música]
el río atrato corre en la selva tropical
del departamento del chuco al oeste de
Colombia
Claudia Roldán originaria del pueblo y
ávida es guardiana del río
Johana especial decidí ser guardiana del
Río atrato
por la necesidad que se veía de tanta
contaminación y tanto desconocimiento
que tiene las demás personas
que están alrededor de su hábitat en el
año 2016 la corte constitucional
reconoció el río atrato como sujeto de
derecho para garantizar su conservación
y protección 14 guardianes como Claudia
trabajan en su preservación con una
distancia de 750 kilómetros este ámbito
natural es uno de los más caudalosos de
Colombia y es esencial para la 500.000
personas que viven a susurrías los
Guardianes se representan legalmente el
atrato y tienen la misión de verificar
que se respeten los derechos que han
sido reconocidos al río es un trabajo
voluntario y a veces complicado no es
fácil que que las personas que nunca han
tenido un acercamiento institucional le
llegue uno como a comentar lo que está
pasando con el río cierto
este día Claudia tiene una reunión con
los otros guardianes en quibdó capital
del departamento y principal el puerto
del Río
[Música]
en este mismo Puerto José Adán Palacio
está cargando su lancha
desde hace mucho rato me desempeño en el
tema de transporte transporte fluvial de
carga y de pasajero en el río atrato y
sus afluentes el mundo de vida de las
comunidades que viven a lo largo de la
trato está basado en la agricultura la
pesca y la minería tradicional tal como
el transporte de mercancías y de
personas
mi papá desde muy pequeño yo lo vi que
él hacía transporte transportando
productos de la región a extraerlos aquí
hasta la capital chocoana y aquí donde
hacía el intercambio O sea que esto ha
sido para nosotros es algo que es
ancestral mientras José Adán carga su
lancha Claudia y los demás guardianes
siguen en su reunión
el balance no es muy alentador en seis
años la minería ilegal aumentó y la
destrucción del río continua avanzando
a unas 4 horas de Egipto nos encontramos
con Ramón Cartagena conocido como Moncho
uno de los guardianes en la localidad de
Carmen de la tracto y nos lleva a 10
kilómetros río abajo del nacimiento de
la trato un lugar que cuando conoció era
muy diferente veníamos con nuestras
familias
Veníamos a hacer los almuerzos de olla
que llamamos nosotros en nuestros
pueblos en nuestro territorio a
compartir con el río Veníamos a pescar
pero hoy desafortunadamente ya vemos el
río en otras condiciones vemos un río
que no nos inspira a tocarlo tan
siquiera y mucho menos a bañarnos como
como lo hacíamos en ese entonces la
razón de este cambio viene de la
instalación de una mina de cobre plata y
platino desde al año 1990
stamina Es legal y en el 2013 pasó a
mano de una multinacional canadiense
Bueno vamos a llegar a la mina ya a la
planta de minero sa y aquí después de
esta curva vamos a mirar la compañía
miren ahí al frente
hoy la mina se ha vuelto el principal
motor económico de la zona Bueno aquí
aquí estamos en toda la lo que es la
parte de la planta de la mina a esta
carretera que estamos viendo acá conduce
a los socavones donde se extrae
precisamente el material yo conozco muy
bien este este sitio Porque además fue
mi trabajo aquí trabajé alrededor de 16
años posteriormente cuando yo me retiro
de acá comienza lo de la sentencia en
donde nos dedicamos a proteger estos
recursos naturales el agua el agua es
vida entonces nos toca como ciudadanos
defender el agua porque es que no nadie
nadie come petróleo nadie come cobre
necesitamos del agua para vivir esta
quebrada que estamos viendo acá esta
quebrada nos muestra como la mina usa
una quebrada para tratar y refinar su
material
las aguas usadas están vertidas en el
atrato de mineral roble si bien Los
guardianes reconocen una mejora en los
últimos años Moncho nos muestra Cómo era
el atrato años atrás
este mismo color que hoy palpamos que
estamos viendo ese era el color
transparente
diáfano cristalino de nuestro río atraco
a pesar de su voluntad monso es
pesimista en cuanto al futuro mientras
que haya minería yo lo veo muy difícil
que podamos
reencontrarnos con ese río de hace 30
años
ese río que hoy no tiene vida
de regreso aquí en el centro de la
ciudad constatamos la presencia de
numerosos compradores de oro uno de
ellos acepta hablarnos de forma anónima
por razones de seguridad
empezó colombiano
da a 840 por 2.25 eso vale billón 890 es
un digamos
un pueblo o una ciudad que todo toda la
economía se mueve alrededor de de la
minería el 90% de la economía se mueve
en eso en la minería lo hecho aquí desde
que llegamos todos nos hablan de la
presencia de minería ilegal con
maquinarias grandes instaladas en los
afluentes de la tracto este comerciante
nos asegura que él solamente compra oro
obtenido vía la minería tradicional
considerada como legal digamos ilegal
son digamos son esas maquinarias grandes
Pero eso no nosotros no no no empezamos
con eso No aparte solamente abaré quiero
que trae certificado de Génesis que nos
pide la alcaldía ya para comprarles
digamos a empresas grandes hay muchos
requisitos como lo extrajo si le hecho
químico no le echó químico entonces así
es mejor la lancha difucia Adán está
cargada y lista para salir pero esta
mañana el motor sin capricho
los peligros del río son numerosos sobre
todo en temporada de lluvias pero la
seguridad es otra problemática ha habido
situaciones donde
a mí no me ha tocado todavía pero si han
habido compañeros que lo han atracado
bandas han perdido todos y ha visto a
veces hasta pérdidas humanas
le preguntamos a José Adán si ha visto
un cambio Desde que la trató se ha
vuelto sujeto de derecho
no a partir de la sentencia de la corte
yo no he visto yo no puedo decir que he
visto cambio en el atrato esto no ha
sido una cosa que se le ha dado
cumplimiento todavía efectivamente
Porque todavía se sigue la contaminación
por minería portada de bosque
indiscriminada
el tema de
las basuras Todavía siguen yendo al río
Entonces yo no he visto un cambio
todavía en esa por esa orden
aparte de ningún pueblo dispone de un
basurero o una alcantarilla
el padre Luis Carlos Hinojosa es el
coordinador del equipo misionero de la
diócesis de Egipto este día sale a
visitar al pared John Jairo
una semana antes de nuestra visita el
padre fue secuestrado unas horas cuando
se desplazaba en el Río La mayoría de
nuestros pueblos del atrato tienen que
nosotros nos movemos hay alguien hay
alguien que que domina y la gente sabe
Quienes son los que más pues los que
están pues como llevando la autoridad la
autoridad de los juegos eso es real y
eso y la gente no sabía es consciente
aquí la Iglesia Católica tuvo un papel
importante en las negociaciones con las
Farc en el proceso de paz concluido en
el 2016 se propone ahora hacerlo con el
Ln una guerrilla que pasé presencia en
el territorio al igual que grupos
paramilitares
esto este tema lo uno más que todo por
la vocación si nos ponemos por el tema
de seguridad pues Nosotros hemos puesto
muertos ya y yo creo que eso de una u
otra manera a con esa actitud hemos
ganado un respeto un cierto respeto por
todos los grupos que están moviéndose
aquí en el en el medio en el medio
la región del chocó es el lugar de una
disputa territorial debida a sus
recursos como en la minería ilegal o la
tala de árboles también es un lugar de
tránsito para el narcotráfico y las
armas un cóctel peligroso para los más
jóvenes que son Víctimas de
reclutamiento
para la iglesia la protección del medio
ambiente se vuelve un pretexto para
alejar a los niños de la violencia
los más fáciles de captar son los niños
los adolescentes los preadolescentes
cuando nosotros impulsamos todo este
tipo de actividades de trabajo Ambiental
de cuidado de nuestras comunidades de a
la misma vez estamos creando unos
entornos protectores porque entonces ya
los niños van a tener un
direccionamiento un objetivo concreto
que hacer por su comunidad y no estarán
tan expuestos para escuchar otras
ofertas que seguramente les estarán
haciendo
María viene a consultar el doctor
Feliciano Moreno porque se siente
mareada ha perdido peso y dice tener
problemas de tensión o algún ha tenido
algún tipo de
alguna situación algún problema que la
haya llevado a tener esa situación
Hace cuánto
en el departamento del chuco hay
solamente dos hospitales públicos y los
municipios cuentan Únicamente con
centros de salud precarios
efectivamente si tiene la presión alta
con esta violencia que tenemos me
imagino que que eso le altera los
nervios
carga muy bien el doctor nos confía que
sus pacientes sufren de problemas de
gastritis de piel y que se ha registrado
altas tasas de mercurio en los
organismos de las personas recomienda
por supuesto No consumir el agua del río
pero tampoco hay ciertas especies de
peces realmente es un agua que está
contaminada y si está contaminada te va
a hacer daño a la salud muchas muertes
se pueden desencadenar del río
seis años después de convertirse en una
entidad jurídica que supuestamente
aseguraría su protección el río atrato
sigue en peligro
maestros O atrato tú qué haces soportado
tanto
brindarle a tus hijos valor para seguir
luchando
interesante la historia Aún falta mucha
disposición de parte de los actores
involucrados para que se detenga la
contaminación
existen otros lugares que sean sujetos
de derecho tanto en Colombia como en
Latinoamérica Pues sí uno puede ser
inclusive que América Latina ha sido
pionera y sigue a la vanguardia en
materia de reconocimientos de derecho a
la naturaleza el país precursor ha sido
Ecuador que cuya constitución en el 2008
reconoció a la pachamama a la madre
tierra derechos siguió Bolivia y hoy
casi todos los países del continente
tienen leyes o tienen sentencias que
reconocen derechos a la naturaleza en
Colombia la decisión de la corte
constitucional del 2016 ha generado toda
una jurisprudencia hay varios Ríos El
cauca el Magdalena en Río
No eso lo hemos mencionado el Quindío y
otros Ríos chiquitos que son sujetos de
derecho hay otros ecosistemas yo
reconoció sujeto de derecho a la laguna
de tota el Amazonas que cubra el 40% del
país es sujeto derecho la pregunta
obviamente es como dice como dice Margot
Qué tan efectiva son es la vía judicial
para proteger los derechos de la
naturaleza y para impactar la acción de
los estados en quibdó la respuesta es
que esta vía judicial es poca efectiva y
en el resto de América Latina es la
misma respuesta gracias a las dos
periodistas por acompañarnos el día de
hoy hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
siga con frases 24
[Música]